by Anthony Davis it's about four and a
half minutes into the fourth quarter he
took a shot from Looney to the side of
the head right there
Davis left the floor
warriors were up 12 at that point
they're up 13 right now no sign of
Anthony Davis and we send it over to
Chris Haynes gosh Anthony Davis was
wheeled out on a wheelchair I believe he
is headed to the locker room right now
for further evaluation but it didn't
look good he had a towel over his head
as they were Wheeling him away so we'll
try to get an update we'll just hope for
the best and unable to leave on his own
power Darvin ham has raised the White
Flag here he's got his bench on the
floor and against 13-point deficit for
the Lakers Russell what a move oh
DeAngelo Russell the little scoop to the
basket and Anthony Davis got hit and is
out of the play and now you're just
going five on four and it's a block on
James Payton counted and one and Davis
still hurt in the backcourt
Anthony Davis obviously got hit was
wobbly
great finish yeah inadvertently Looney's
forearm sort of smacks him there and
then LeBron James just turns his body a
little bit Peyton finishes and is going
to the free-throw line and Anthony Davis
is going to go back to the bench
and again and we've seen this throughout
the series Davis came out of the gates
hard had a really big first half and
then has sort of disappeared on the
offensive end of the floor
now the defense has been spectacular
was the man responsible for curry in the
closing minutes of game four but he is
really nuggets Sons after that this is
the shot by the Looney the elbow to the
head of Davis
and after sitting on the bench for a
moment the medical staff has taken him
back to the locker room Chris Haynes was
right there with him what'd you see
Chris
for evaluation I will tell you as they
were walking and escorting them ad
didn't look as stable he needed a little
bit of help walking he appears to be a
little bit dizzy so as soon as I get an
update I will relay it as soon as
possible that's an excellent observation
and he showed the same on the floor he
was wobbly
after that shot so without Anthony Davis
the Lakers down 12 warriors with the
ball six and a half to go in regulation
of game five